[Music]
good afternoon and welcome everyone as
you know hybrid and multi cloud are big
big themes this year and next today we
want to put ourselves in the shoes of a
cloud administrator to understand the
challenges of managing large cloud
workloads
in a context where hybrid and multi
cloud are the norm we will see how you
can leverage DevOps tooling and best
practices to manage your cloud workloads
consistently across environments how you
can improve your security posture how
you can establish governance and make
compliance easier at scale yesterday we
announced anthos and we showed our
anthers config management allows you to
manage your kubernetes environments on
premise and in the cloud through code
today we will walk you through a live
demo that shows how you can use anthos
to manage your traditional GCP resources
and policies as code my name is Marco
Cavalli and I'm a product manager in
Google cloud and today Alex and zhuzhing
will join us also they are also from
Google and Alex will talk about the
config validator and Suzanne will walk
us through the demo so we said we want
to put ourselves in the customer
administrator or the cloud administrator
or shoes and I use the term cloud
administrator broadly to refer to the
most common administrative functions in
Google cloud you can think of it as the
person or the theme the team that is
responsible for security and compliance
for your company now the cloud
administrator is at the center of
complex ecosystem on one side you have
requirements that your company needs to
meet there are security compliance
governance auditability requirements and
these are top of mind for freedom
all companies across any industry and
then you have stakeholders that rely on
the administrator to do their job there
are developers that need to move fast
but also want to know that there are
guardrails in place to protect them
there are auditors they need to have
access to logs and change history so
that they can sign off on your
compliance requirements with confidence
and there are financial controllers who
want to be able to set budgets for
waters and track usage so that when the
cloud bill comes in they are not
surprised to support your stakeholders
and to meet your requirements as the
cloud administrator you have a large set
of controls you have our authorization
and authentication policies the control
who can use your resources and how they
can use the your resources and which
resources they can use you have
organization policies that allow you to
set guardrails to make sure that your
users stay within the compliance
boundaries you have firewall rules that
control traffic between different
services or different resources all of
these have different interfaces
different best practices different
syntaxes these are knobs that you use to
control resources and resources can be
in Google cloud but can be also in your
data center maybe you're running
traditional viens or you're running
kubernetes probably you have other cloud
providers too so complexity can easily
become overwhelming especially if you're
managing everything manually moving from
one UI to the other calling individual
api's this is non scalable and
error-prone it also leads to some
challenges one of the challenges is
visibility
so how do you make sure that you
maintain and comprehensive overview of
what's going on in your cloud
environments if you have to deal with
different interfaces and different
syntaxes and different best practices
how
you ensure that loopholes are not
created somewhere without you realizing
or how do you ensure that your resources
don't drift after compliance over time
and related to this is auditability how
do you keep track of changes and how do
you report them in a way that is easily
consumable by non-technical stakeholders
and then as you spare this your business
grows how do you make sure that you
don't become the bottleneck how you said
we want to enable developers to move
fast so how do you do that in a scalable
way to sustain a business growth without
slowing it down
so again doing things manually is a
problem so standardization and
automation are key to enable scalability
and finally how do you discover when new
features or new configurations or
policies become available with cloud
providers rolling out new features at an
increasing pace how do you keep up and
how do you ensure that your environments
are up to date all the time well you can
go through like pages of documentation
or you can read blog post or you can
reach out to your cloud support but
again this is not scalable how can we
help you make it simpler and more
immediate and this again is in a world
where hybrid and multi cloud are just
standard so complexity is in itself an
issue and a challenge but the more
important part is that complexity may
lead to an increased vulnerability for
your company it is surprisingly easy to
open up a VM with sensitive data to the
Internet or to give access to a storage
bucket a test PII data to the entire
world these are example of miss
configurations and we know that miss
configurations are in many cases the
root cause of vulnerability or data
breaches or leaks and miss
configurations are in for the majority
caused by human error so how do we
improve your security and how do we
reduce the risk of
miss configuration again doing things
manually pressing buttons in you eyes is
dangerous it's not easily trackable and
is not controllable so again automation
and standardization are critical so as I
was learning about this space a while
ago and I was trying to understand the
separation of concern between the
administrator and the developer and my
friend Ray came up with an interesting
analogy so he told me you know when a
company moves to the cloud is like
buying a large apartment building with
the goal of renting out apartments and I
was like oh that sounds interesting but
tell me more and he said think about it
the building has an administrator that's
the building administrator and that is
equivalent to the cloud administrator
and tenants or prospective tenants are
like your developers in the cloud so as
the building onion administrator you
want to provide apartments to your
tenants so they can move in and live
there and in the cloud as the cloud
administrator you want to provision
resources that are like the apartment
you want to provision them to your
developers so that they can go on and
build their own application and you want
to do that in the within the law in the
apartment building and within compliance
requirements in the cloud so your goal
is to maximize your utilization free up
your developers but stay within
compliance and before you start renting
out apartments as the administrator you
probably want to set up some rules to
create a healthy environment for example
you want to set access rule and and make
sure that every tenant has a key to
enter the building or make sure that
when there are visitors they check in at
the front desk and then you can use set
rules to control how the building itself
is used there are rules that for example
say there shouldn't be parties after
10:00 p.m. or rule under a rule that
says tenant shouldn't set up a machine
shop in their apartment or they
shouldn't be tearing down
like randomly so these are like the
basic rules for for a happy cohabitation
and in the cloud the equivalent of those
rules are the policies you have policies
that apply to users like authentication
and authorization you can enforce for
example that all your users use a second
factor authentication to sign in and
when they are in you can control which
resources they can access to do what and
then there are policies that apply to
resources you may want for example to
organize resources in a way that creates
separations between the different
tenants and you can do that in GCP using
folders or you can use the name spaces
in kubernetes and then you can use
policies like organization policies to
set guardrails in compliance and
governance or you can use building and
quota to control usage or networking and
monitoring and and so on and so forth
now to wrap up this analogy before you
rent out the apartment you probably want
to establish a process that is easily
scalable repeatable and as automate as
automated as possible and you can do
that by for example providing a few
options you can say that you have a done
a few sizes of apartments and they're
like the quota in there in the cloud or
you can have some furnished apartment
and some that are non furnished and then
you can provide or prepare different
templates for different contracts so
when a new tenant shows up they give you
their requirements you take the
corresponding contract they sign it and
they are off to the races and of course
you want to make sure that you control
what's going on too so that things run
smoothly and nothing crazy happens now
in the cloud and those configuration
management allows you to do that it
allows you to streamline management of
your environments across across clouds
or on-premise using code as as the way
to do it and it uses the kubernetes
declarative style to ensure that there
is a consistent experience
across different environments because it
uses code it stores that code in a
unified source of truth which is stored
in Aggies repository and the git
repository is the user experience around
managing your configurations and your
infrastructure across hybrid environment
and again because we use a code then you
can leverage things like prism it checks
to prevent bad configuration from being
pushed into production or you can ensure
that whenever a change is submitted and
merged it gets automatically picked up
by the CI CD pipeline and automatically
deployed to recurrence to the
corresponding infrastructure now let's
look at the conflict management stuck a
little bit in more detail there's an
authoring layer that is where you define
your configurations and we said we rely
on on code we use a git repository and
we use the kubernetes declarative style
and we'll look at that a little bit in
in a moment
the second key step is the validation
and again it's a way for you to define
rules that prevent bad configurations
from being pushed into production and
this helps you in two ways primarily one
is that allows you to establish
governance you can codify rules that
represent your requirement and those
rules need to be met before anything is
pushed and merged into the into the
master branch and the second level is it
it helps reduce toil for the
administrator it does that because as
the administrator you know that whenever
a pull request reaches your Inbox
it's already gone through all your
checks so you can focus on the real
important things what needs to have
human attention you don't need to check
every single thing and you can use
automation in fact to limit the pull
requests that need to be reviewed
manually and I was talking to a customer
recently and they have two security
administrator for the entire company and
for them being able to set those rules
and automate those checks is
because otherwise as today they have to
review every single pool request which
is obviously non-scalable now once the
pool request has been reviewed and
submitted and and approved Danny gets
picked up its merged into the master
branch and he's picked up and all
actuate it into the corresponding
platform and this is where things become
real on one side you have your intent
and the actuation layer picks up your
intent and translates it into API calls
that call the corresponding settings and
policy systems in the different
platforms and finally intelligence gives
you recommendation and using uses
machine learning so look at your user
path usage pattern to improve your
security posture let's look at this
layer a little more in more detail so we
say that the authoring layer is done
through code and is done in gate now we
are not prescriptive as to where you
should host your git repository but we
are prescriptive Oregon on the structure
of the repository the structure as
semantics and it means that it
represents how your resources are
organized in the cloud so we use folders
to represent projects and folders in GCP
or namespaces in kubernetes and files
are ml files and they represent
resources and their policy bindings and
as we see in a moment we use the
kubernetes declarative style again to
represent your resources and your
policies because git is your source of
truth then you can use easily DevOps
tooling and best practices you can build
prism it checks like we said in a moment
ago but you can also leverage things
like approval the pull request and
approval workflows so that changes don't
get merged automatically into your
master branch but it has to have to be
reviewed and approved by another
administrator before they become
effective and then you can use things
like roll backs or
gradual rollouts so that you don't
immediately affect all your users in one
second
now if you are an existing customer and
you have managed you have a number of
resources already deployed and you're
managing them manually
you probably wonder how am I going to
start well we provide you with the
importer tool and zhuzhing will show how
that works and this important takes
everything you have in your DCP DePaul
environments and dumps it into a brand
new repo and you can then hit the road
running very quickly and finally because
everything is s code you can you can use
templates and templates are like the
contract that we talked about earlier
for your developer so you can build your
own templates but you can also access
templates from public lab or open source
libraries and Alex will talk about that
in a moment we are also working to
provide an extensive library library of
templates with best practices for
different industry verticals there was a
session yesterday they talked about
templates for financial services and
over the course of 2019 we will extend
those to other industrial verticals too
so just a second on the kubernetes
resource model it has it provides two
benefits one is that it is declarative
and it represents your desire state so
the advantage here is that you express
your intent and you store it in a git
repository and then you can use tooling
to make sure that your intent is
deployed and it comes consistently
refreshed and mapped into your resources
so that your resources always reflect
your intent and the second benefit is
that it allows you to abstract the
infrastructure using crts so custom
resource definition you can create a
logical abstraction of your
infrastructure and you can use that to
express configurations and settings in a
consistent way across different
environments in a way that is in
structure agnostic so that it can easily
be mapped onto different platform
seamlessly now the validation is
something that Alex will talk about in
more detail so it won't spend much time
but just two quick notes the validation
we said helps you prevent bad
configuration from being pushed and you
can do that by defining your own rules
and those rules are like two level of
controls one is like basic limiters you
can use them to prevent things like
syntax errors or if you are trying to
create a resource that's already
existent it will give you an error those
errors are caught immediately so they
don't even get pushed into into anything
they are caught and stopped
automatically and the second level of
control you can actually Express rules
that represent your governance intent
and your governance requirements so that
whenever a push goes through them it
only passes if it meets your compliance
requirements we said the activation is
where things become real so after
somebody has submitted a pull request
that pull request has been verified
through all the automated checks and
then it's gone to the administrator who
has approved it then it is picked up
automatically by the CIC the pipeline
and deployed to the corresponding
infrastructure and in the demo we will
focus on the actuation for GCP resources
specifically now intelligence is the
last layer and intelligence we said it
helps you optimize your security posture
and you can do that in different levels
and we can use an analogy from the car
industry to make it more clear so the
first level is - it helps you understand
what is going on in your different
deployments it actually understand which
resources do you have and what is the
status of those resources and what the
history behind those resources it's like
the dashboard in a car you have the
speedometer you have the fuel gauge you
have the temperature but then decisions
are left to the driver this is
information that you can use to make
your decision
the tooling is not giving you more than
that and then the second layer is
actually the validator and that helps
you prevent mistakes it's like the blind
spot sensor in in a car in the rearview
mirror of the car so before you commit
to changing lane it you you make sure
that nobody's is is coming so you can do
that safely the third layer is the
troubleshooter the troubleshooter is
alpha 4 I am and it helps you understand
when things are going wrong why they are
going wrong for example if I try to spin
up a new VM and I get a permission
denied it actually understand which
permissions you need so that you can do
it correctly or you can submit a pull
request to request those permissions and
it's like the Diagnostics diagnostic
system in the car it has to understand
why the car is not working and finally
the more intelligent part it uses
machine learning to analyze your usage
and it gives you a recommendation on how
you can improve your security posture
and the I am recommend that is also
available today and yeah I am
recommender looks at let's say Marco he
has 25 I am roles but over the last six
months is only used to so you may want
to reduce that which brings you closer
to the principle of least privilege and
in general it reduces yours error search
phase and this is like maps in a car
that helps you go somewhere so let's
bring it all together now we said we
have a source of truth it's in a git
repository we are prescriptive about the
structure of the repository but you can
host it in any in any solution so we
support github or github or crowdsource
repo and and everything is stored at
code as code and then you can plug into
any CI CD pipeline and then the
validator integrates with them so in the
demo we will show github and cloud build
google cloud build but you can also use
Travis or Jenkins or bamboo and others
the validated actuation
picks up the changes and deploys them to
the to the platform they can be GCP or
it can be kubernetes on-premise and then
the intelligence part and the
intelligence part has the analysis part
that is for SETI is an open-source tool
but you also have cloud asset inventory
as I mentioned and then the intelligence
that gives you recommendation and those
recommendations are represented as pull
requests and those pull requests come
from the tooling not from a human and
they are fed back into the into the git
repository so you can review them and
you can decide which one makes sense to
you where do they impact your resources
and whether you want to accept it or
accept them or not and with this I would
like to invite Alex on stage Alex will
walk you through the validator and will
introduce the demo Thank You Marco hello
ladies and gentlemen
so I'm Alex a fellow product manager
working here on TCP CSP as Marko
mentioned earlier today we talked a lot
about validator and I'm going to dive a
little bit deeper today at the same time
I'm also going to be introducing our
sample customer over here chili oregano
so chili oregano is an e-commerce
service where with one tap you can order
the freshest spiciest and most organic
Chili's to your doorsteps now chili
oregano recently faced a data breach
issue for some reason somehow within
inside some other developers got Gmail
access into their restricted and
sensitive data this is essentially spun
into break out the headline section
where hey chili oregano is not keeping
their customers data safe these things
happen
they sound like exaggerated situations
but there are real scenarios that can
happen to you so we want to explore how
can chili oregano
stop these type of incidents for
happening in the first place now let's
introduce some of the players that we'll
be talking about very soon within our
demo the first is me Alice Alice is our
cloud administrator and going back to
the building ology there Marco
mentioned earlier she is similar to the
building administrator Alice cares
deeply about setting guardrails around
keeping the environment safe and secure
and at the same time though Alice does
care about her developers one of their
key stakeholders she wants to make sure
that they are free to go build the best
applications and services possible today
Alice is managing all of her resources
manually tomorrow though Alice is
looking to you on board into anthos
config management and be able to
leverage the powers of scalability and
automation the second key player we want
to meet is Bob now bob is one of Chile
Oregano's top developers as I mentioned
before bob cares about moving fast he
doesn't really care about policies he
just wants to build cool services and
applications but at the same time bob
knows about the dangers of having
insecure code he doesn't want to be the
perpetrator of a deadly sort of headline
so bob cares about his Co being secure
safe before it rolls into production and
with that let me talk a little bit about
validator a solution for custom security
and governance guardrails
how can validator help solve both alice
the administrator and bob the developers
goals validator comes as a two-pronged
solution the first side is during pre
deployment checks how can we check
whether a configuration has any
violations before we even provision it
or actuate it into our platforms in
short how do we stop these misfit miss
configurations before they happen the
second is going to be on ongoing
monitoring and this acts sort of as a
checks and balance if a violation does
enter your platform how do we find it
how do we identify it and here I want to
talk about violations there are two key
ones that we have to keep on top of our
mind the first is break glass violations
so as we mentioned this is an
infrastructure as
solution everything's being done as code
but developers knowing how smart they
are sometimes they find things around
just to get things done what if a
developer goes directly into the cloud
console uses g-cloud or maybe even
writes up their own script in order to
make some changes within your platform
now for developers they may feel happy
but as Alice an administrator we want to
keep things secure so with ongoing
monitoring we're able to identify these
violations so that way Alice the
administrator can decide what to do with
them the second type of violation that
we care about our retroactive violations
so initially your platform has all of
its resources in a current state but as
you employ new constraints or new
policies or new rules some of these old
resources may now be in violation how do
we find and identify these violations so
that way Alice can choose whether to
remediate or to keep as an exception now
the glue that ties both of these sites
together and the key to validator is
actually this single source of truth
this repo of validator constraints
imagine these constraints as the ability
to write your governance best practice
and security rules one time they have it
run everywhere across tools both in the
provisioning side and in the monitoring
side from other perspective this also
makes it simple for you to have one
source of truth for you to showcase hey
here's all of the actual governance
rules that are applied within my company
diving a little bit deeper as Marco
mentioned everything is going to be
defined as kubernetes style
yeah moles so alice administrator can
very simply configure one of these to
instantiate a new policy or a new rule
now there is a little bit of business
logic in the backend which I'll get you
in a few slides but at the front very
simply if if Alice wants to create one
of these new constraints such as to stop
the access from Gmail cow or other
outside domain how can she do that today
so here we have a
with domain restriction constraint and
let me walk you through a few of the
different parameters we have here
starting at the top we have the template
kind so this defines the type of check
that is going to be done in the
background to enforce and as I mentioned
already this is going to be the domain
restriction constraint the second is a
free-form text for the company's name so
over here
Alice simply named say the chileo
original domain restriction the third is
a piece of metadata that's going to be
very critical and no pun intended during
your remediation stages Alice wants to
be able to sell whether a certain policy
or whether certain constraint it's going
to be low medium or high when this
information is surfaced to the ongoing
monitoring tools the tool will then know
hey is this something of low severity so
that way maybe we should kick it off to
some sort of internal workflow for
ticketing and approval or is it so
severe such as giving access to a gmail
account on our PII restrictive data that
we want to do Auto remediation we want
to either remove access immediately or
we may even want to lock down the
resource in some other way the fourth of
these is the target what's the scope of
where you want this constraint to take
place
so over here based on CCP's research
hierarchy you can define it as the
organization the folder or the project
level in addition you can also set
exceptions for example it should only
apply to your set of projects while
excluding some other ones and very
lastly we actually get to the parameters
and this is what Alice will care most
about when she's configuring one of
these constraints these parameters will
tie directly back to the constraint kind
that we defined earlier so in this
scenario since we are limiting or
restricting only a set of allowed
domains Alice has set the G service
accounts the only Google service
accounts is allowed as well as her own
company Chile oregano now you may be
wondering okay we talked a little bit
about these constraint kinds and
templates where do I actually get the
right well this is where Google we're
going with the open-source strategy the
policy library is already public and
live today it is again open source
community generated and it's gonna be a
single location where we can imagine
different large players across different
industries whether it's healthcare
retail finance to be able to contribute
and build different types of constraints
for their niche or their industry
specific needs over time at the same
time though Google also will be a key
contributor to this policy library we
will be looking at our best practices
from a security perspective product
perspective and even from our own
professional services teams these will
be Google's opinionated constraints as
we slowly push these into the policy
library starting today though just for
you to play with we will have a handful
of these constraints I've already talked
about the iam domain restriction we will
also have restriction of VM instances
with public eye piece enforcement of
network routing and enforcement of
storage logging now I alluded to this a
little bit earlier for the simple use
case of for Alice where she just wants
to use some sort of pre-existing
constraint template she just has to
accentuate that llamó file we showed
earlier but what if Alice wants to do
more what if she wants to customize
something what if she wants to have the
agility to constrain something but
Google or other players within the
community has not provided inside that
policy library yet well this is where we
want to empower the infra infrastructure
architects cloud admin teams for them to
be able to roll out and build their own
custom constraint templates I won't go
through the exact details here but these
templates will be written in reco it is
a dynamic and popular policy language
and the example I have here is for the
actual enforcement of storage logging so
as you can see it's only a small number
of code to do something that's very very
critical circling back let's revisit
what Alice and Bob will be doing today
now that we talked a little bit
about the validator solution so in our
demo we're gonna show Alice first
initializing that git repo as we call
the source of truth with the importer
service she will then be checking out
the policy library to get all of those
constraint templates we talked about and
configured the domain restriction
constraint next we will swap over to Bob
again our top developer who is now
looking to create a new project let's
call this the fulfilment project where
he will also be binding some iron
policies now Bob may be doing something
a little bit naughty so I won't be going
to details on exactly what you could
probably guess though but as he's going
through this process of checking his
code trying to roll this new project
he'll be diagnosing some of the
violations that validator captures
eventually though he'll be able to put
poor successful and healthy pull
requests and circling back to Alice who
will get this pull request
she will review approve before
eventually merging this into their
master branch afterwards with Ethel's
config management we will see the
actualization into the platform itself
and to bring this all together as Mark
alluded to earlier how does this all fit
into different stages life cycles so
again Alice she will be doing the
authoring step with the import into the
source of truth Bob will be doing the
publishing and working against this
source of truth before passing it back
to Alice to do the automation around
validation and actualization into GCP so
with that I would like to invite Zhu Zin
my colleague so you actually run us
through a live demo of what anthos plus
validator will look like 6x
hello everyone my name is Susan I'm a
software engineer from Google cloud so
next I'm going to run the simple live
demo about Angela's config management so
let's get started so now imagine I'm
Alice the cloud administrator from Chile
original so my company has resources in
GCP that we are currently managing
manually so the resource hierarchy is
organized as follows
it's quite simple to folders under our
organization engineering and people ops
and each has two products we have
checkout service project showing her
service project and the engineering
folder and HR system and payroll
projects and the people opps so that's
pretty simple now I decided to adopt the
Anschluss config management to avoid the
disaster that Alek my colleague Alec
just mentioned about so I have created a
git repository on github as you can see
this repository is currently empty
without resources and I have already
turned on and source country management
for this repo so next I'm going to
translate my organization into this repo
so that answers can start many I'm going
to do that using the importer service so
I go to my Crown shell already Chrome
this repo in my environment as you can
see it's currently empty so for this
demo I put all the commands I need to
run in a demo script don't just run the
demo script
so the first I'm going to run the
importer service so what importer
service does is pretty straightforward
it's going to translate my organization
specified by the ID including all the
resources and I'm policies into this
repo so we can start managing so now
let's open the cloud editor now we see
that it creates a hierarchy directory so
the hierarchy directory here Maps
exactly to the GCB hierarchy we just saw
and my colleague Mercury briefly
explained the structure here so let's go
over them with a little bit more details
so issue director here represents a
single GCP resource at the top level we
see there the GCP
there's an organization chili oregano
and there's the GCP organization damo
indicating that this is the an
organization resource and this file
contains all the metadata for this
resource for example is ID and is the
GCP name and there's also AG cpi-m
policy do ya know
which contains all the IM policies for
this resource and we see that there are
two directories under the organization
folder engineering and food are people
opps representing the two folders under
this organization further down we can
see that there are two directories under
the folder engineering project check out
service and product shopping cart
service representing the two projects
under the folder engineering so in
addition to this resource and I am
policies I also want to keep my camera's
environment safe with security best
practices such as restricting my
company's resource access to only in the
members from my company's domain so I'm
going to create such a domain
restriction constraint in this repo so
how do I do that
so my colleague Alex has already
mentioned this in his slides that we
have the open stores policy library so
normally I will just need to clone the
library into my repo and I can modify
the policy templates to create my custom
tourist constraints so in this demo I'm
just going to copy over some policy
constraints that I already put in my
local repo so I'm going to check out the
policy library as you can see now
there's one more directory called
policies there are constraints and
templates
open this file so this is a domain
restriction constraint over I am members
which Alex are already explained in a
lot of details so here I'm going to
whitelist my company's domain
I'm going to add TD oregano
okay so now with resources
I am policies and policy constraints I'm
okay so I feel ready
I was amid all these changes and
everything come in and pushed origin
okay so now let's do a quick recap as a
crowd administrator I decide to adopt
and source config management so I create
a git repository to be the central
source of truth from organization
I use the importer service to
automatically translate my organization
into this repo to start managing I then
put policy constraint files in this repo
to keep my comm breezing environment
safe and secure now this repo is fully
instantiated and is ready to be used so
now imagine and Bob the developer from
Chile oregano so I'm going to work on
the new fulfillment service project and
I'm going to create this product under
the engineering folder so as now right
now my company is moving towards answers
config management so as they are or I
don't have direct access to cloud
counselor anymore I cannot go to console
and create my project here and manually
specify that I am policies there instead
I'll be doing all of that through the
repo by going through the co review
process with that I'm going to my cloud
shell and I'm also going to run the
script so as a developer the first thing
I need to do is I'm going to clone my
comedy's repository into my local
environment as we can see all the data
is here let's open the crochet editor
now the repo is here containing
everything that Adam e arrays just
pushed
so I'm going to create this product
under the folder engineering how am I
going to do that so just like the two
other existing project checkout service
and showing car service I'm going to do
that by creating a new directory for my
product so I'm going to navigate to this
directory and in this demo I'm going to
just copy over the files that I prepared
beforehand so now you see I have create
a new directory under the folder
engineering is called project
fulfillment and I have created a GCP
project the llamó which contains the man
leader for my new project and name my
product fulfillment service and in the
GCB I am policy the llamo a specified
pub from gmail.com as a project editor
now as a developer I'm going to create a
pull request
critical request so now the pull request
just created and you see that a cloud
build runs immediately so car build in
this case perform as or pre-islamic
checks it runs our config validator
which does a bunch of sanity checks
against or repo for example it checks
for project ID duplication it cannot
have two products having the same ID it
also checks for GCP hierarchy violations
for example we cannot have to create a
GCP product and our another GCB product
in addition to that it also checks for I
am policy violations against the rules
the post constituents that we put into
this repo actually in this case we see
that our bill actually has failed so
let's go to count build page so this is
the one we just run open it so from the
loft we see that it's reporting two
errors one fung tube tape for the ID
shopping her service so if we circle
back this is basically complaining that
I'm using a duplicated Product ID so
this ID already exists today on GDP and
second error complaint file a Tong
stream violation so contains member from
is Peggy domain that Bob at gmail.com so
this is basically because Bob has
specified his personal gmail account as
a product edit which clearly violates
the policy constraints or violates the
company's compliance so with these two
errors as a developer I've realized that
I should really be running the config
validator locally before I even creates
pull requests so go back to my repo I'm
going to run the config verdi there too
take a while so indeed is reporting
these two violations the domain
violation and the product ID evaluation
so let's pick these two errors first
let's let's not use Gmail which violates
the rule let's use Chile original and
let's give the new product a unique ID
state cool now let's run the config
validator to again see this time there's
no errors so I'm going to update the
pull request now Carl Bildt runs again
let's open the logs so well crow Beauty
is running let's do another quick recap
so as a developer I propose config
changes through the repo by creating new
pull requests and the config validator
will capture and report any errors that
introduced by my config changes I will
be able to fix these pet errors before
the bad changes get pushed to underlying
production so now in this case we see
that Robert is happy so now imagine I'm
Alice the cloud administrator again so I
receive a notification of a new pull
request so I go to my github account
open this pull request actually I
noticed that all checks I passed for
this pull request which is great I go
inspect the code changes I see that Bob
is going to create a fulfillment service
project and bob has specified his
corporal count as the project editor so
the code looks fun to me I'm going to
merge this pull request directly
so now the poor request gets merged so
what happens next
so this repo is already being enabled
with Enzo's config management and the
master branch is currently being
actively monitored by the service so if
it detects any new changes it will
automatically pick them up and apply to
the underlying GCP platform that means
the new product fulfillment service
product will get created automatically
on GCP and Bob will be specified as a
product editor so now let's go to the
console and verify its refresh so now we
see that fulfillment service product
appears rather than right under the
engineering folder if you look at I am
policies now pop as Chile Oregon over
comm is now specified as a product
editor so yeah that's pretty much the
demo I have for today with that I'm
going to hand over to Marko so Thank You
Suzanne and let's recap what we saw
today and let's summarize we started and
we took the perspective of a cloud
administrator and we saw the challenges
that as an administrator you have when
you have to manage workloads and
configurations across hybrid
environments and then we saw how anthos
config management helps you with that it
had to improve your security posture by
leveraging DevOps tooling and DevOps
workflows so that you can enforce
governance and and improve security and
compliance and and zhuzhing show how
that works in a live demo so there are a
number of sessions that cover topics
that are related to this one some have
already happened
some one is tomorrow morning or tomorrow
afternoon but you'll find them on on
YouTube so I encourage you to go and
look for them because they are all very
interested and interesting and related
and thank you so much
[Music]